our main story tonight concerns organs
what I personally think should be inside
of pinatas children have to learn that
their actions have
consequences specifically we're going to
talk about organ and body donation organ
transplants are a topic that's been
covered on TV in many profound ways
including in this moving clip
5 Dr
Casper Dr Casper
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that is what is known in the
business as excellent television
we've actually shown you that clip
before on the show Shing a story about
and this is true police
interrogations and we will absolutely
show it to you again whenever the
we feel like it but the point is organ
donation is extremely important which is
why there are so many ads encouraging
you to do it as well as TV commercials
and PSAs perhaps none more brilliant
than this one from Australia have you
thought about maybe becoming an organ
donor is this really the best time to
bring this up oh we get it you know no
one wants to talk about
death but you know not all of us are
going to the uh Eternal paradise and uh
your organs could save the lives of up
to six people seven seven people not to
mention how your bones and and soft
tissue and ligaments could change the
lives of many others and Corners you'll
help blind people see what a miracle
obviously I would do it I'm Jesus right
of course Jesus would do it though I
will say Jesus having none of his vital
organs might complicate his resurrection
3 Days Later Easter probably wouldn't be
as big if it celebrated the day Jesus
rose from the dead and then instantly
died again from renal failure but that
ad is Right organ donation saves lives
and here in the US it is widely popular
surveys have consistently found 90% or
more of Americans indicating their
support for organ donation and around
half of respondents to a recent survey
had signed up as donors and a lot of
lives get saved this way last year there
were over 42,000 organ transplants
performed here in the US but the system
that handles our donations has
considerable flaws which sometimes leak
into public view through stories like
this one about a donor heart that was
being sent for processing to make
life-saving tissue grafts a Southwest
Airlines flight had to turn around
because someone left a human heart on
board this happened over the weekend
this was a donor heart of course headed
to a clinic in Seattle from Sacramento
but someone apparently forgot to unload
the heart when it reached Seattle my
understanding is that the pilot made an
announcement when they turned around uh
that they were returning because there
was a heart that had been left on board
that is awful first I left your heart on
a Southwest flight 100% sounds like a
Lana Del re lyric but but also it's
worth mentioning a few years ago
Southwest celebrated their 50th
anniversary with a campaign featuring
this graphic and the words 50 years one
heart which probably should have been
updated to Read 50 years one heart that
we totally forgot about and almost sent
to Dallas and while we thankfully had
over 42,000 trans
last year the list of those waiting for
one is over a 100,000 people long with
17 people dying each day waiting for a
transplant making it pretty frustrating
that experts say many thousands more
could be done each year if our organ
transplant system functions smoothly
it's frankly no wonder people are
desperately trying to circumvent the
system by posting Craigslist ads putting
up social media posts or even doing this
Mark needs a kidney and now because of
this giant billboard that vital m
message is reaching hundreds of
thousands of people as they pass through
the crossroads of the world it's true a
man in need of a kidney resorted to
putting up a giant billboard in Time
Square and that is clearly not what
Billboards should be used for they
should be used to advertise Broadway
musicals sportsware or a weird bird that
someone wants to win a contest on the
other side of the world for some reason
now the good news is that ad helped that
man to find a living Kidney donor but
again many aren't that fortunate and the
issue here isn't just with organs
because in a completely separate process
each year around 20,000 Americans
generously donate their whole bodies to
science but that system has its own
issues because the definition of what
constitutes science can be pretty loose
your body could end up educating medical
students but it could also end up
somewhere like the Museum of Osteology
in Oklahoma City this is our human
exhibit so when somebody agrees to
donate their body to science they could
end up here it's possible they could end
up here MH do you think though that
people when they think about a donation
of of their body to science that this is
an example of that I would automatically
think it would be yes you sure about
that when most people think about
donating their body to science they
picture it in a reputable educational
institution not in some roadside bone
collection face down ass up arranging a
formation best described as cir toay
performers favorite sex position the
fact fact is our donated organs while
being incredibly important to saving
lives are not getting into enough people
and our donated bodies incredibly
important to advancing knowledge aren't
always treated with the care they
deserve so tonight let's talk about our
donation systems for both and let's
start with the system for organs organ
transplants are fairly recent the first
successful operation only took place in
1954 for a little perspective that was
the year Oprah was born organ
transplantation is only one Oprah old
from there transplantation slowly became
more common and in 1984 Congress passed
the national organ transplant act that
bans the sale of human organs and
actually opened up access by
establishing a National Registry for
organ matching to be run by a private
nonprofit under government contract and
the organization that's held it ever
since is called Unos or the United
Network for organ sharing it's a
national body that's HS the top 56
Regional organ procurement organizations
and we'll get into them in a little bit
but Unos also manages the Nationwide
transplant waiting list and in this
documentary from 20 years ago the head
of Unos explained the logistics they're
go to deciding who gets which organ many
people think that the way the waiting
list works is that once a person is on
the list that they just simply stay on
the list until time has passed and they
move up to the top of the list and
receive an organ but it does not work
that way uh it's a very Dynamic and
fluid situation in which each person is
evaluated based on medical criter
criteria matched with information that's
placed in the computer about each organ
donor right well you might assume that
you just get on the list wait your turn
an organ arrives for you at the hospital
and a dog eats it off the floor while
everyone nearby just kind of rolls with
it the actual matching process changes
constantly based on which organs are
available and which patients most need
them and in theory that sounds amazing
but there are multiple problems for
starters Uno's computer systems leave a
lot to be desired a government report in
2021 cited age software periodic system
failures mistakes in programming and
over Reliance on manual input of data
investigators even cited multiple system
outages with one from 2 years ago
lasting about 3 hours which isn't good
because every minute matters when it
comes to the viability of an organ for
transplant and as anyone whove seen
killers of the flower Moon can tell you
3 hours can be an incredibly long time
but it's not just technical errors there
are also serious issues with some of the
ways Unos has ranked patients in terms
of need most notably when it comes to
kidneys for years it allowed transplant
centers to employ something called a
black race coefficient which is just as
bad as it sounds very basically
hospitals miscalculated black patients
kidney function based on racist junk
science that said black bodies have
higher muscle mass that made black
patients appear healthier than they were
pushing them down the kidney transplant
list and it's one reason why even though
black people are four times as likely to
develop kidney failure as white people
they are much less likely to receive a
transplant and while you know's
transplant Network did approve the
elimination of race based calculations
they only did that last year and have
given hospitals until January of next
year to update their waiting list which
feels like too long considering that the
correct time to fix that problem is
ages ago and then there's the
fact that rich people can essentially
cut the light the way they can do this
is by registering themselves at multiple
transplant hospitals in multiple states
with a plan to fly somewhere on a
moment's notice if if one becomes
available it's called multiple listing
and it's how in 2009 Steve Jobs was able
to get a liver in a matter of weeks in
Memphis despite living in California
where there was a long wait list but
there's an obvious reason that that
policy doesn't work for people who
aren't billionaire CEOs have you ever
been told that you can be on multiple
lists and centers all over the country
no that would be a great idea we explain
the costs could you afford to fly to
those places no
I don't think so of course booking a
last minute ticket can be really
expensive even on a cheap airline like
the one whose logo reminds you that they
once lost track of a human heart on one
of their Greyhound buses of the
sky and there's one final issue with
Unos which that is supposed to also
coordinate shipping of organs between
regions for instance a kidney that
matches a rare blood type may need to be
flown to another state but even there it
relies on a primitive system of phone
calls and paper manifest with no GPS or
other electronic tracking required and
that combined with fuckups by Airlines
and local organizations helps explain
why nearly 170 organs over a recent
5-year period could not be transplanted
due to transportation problems kidneys
have shown up late damaged or in one
case in a package that was squished with
apparent tire marks on it and no doctor
should have to use a flattened organ
they're performing a transplant not
making kidney
picata one director of a transplant
center sums up the current situation
like this when you order a toothbrush on
Amazon they can tell you minute to
minute where that toothbrush is well
that's not been possible for organ
transplantation even though we think
that what we do is considerably more
important than ordering a toothbrush
look we should obviously be able to
track organs as easily as we track
Amazon packages and do you realize how
shitty your organization has to be for
me to say be more like Amazon things
have to be pretty spicy for me to look
into a camera and say with my actual
mouth please be more like the soulless
Mega Corporation created by evil Mr
Clean here so to put it mildly younos
could and should be doing a lot better
and I will say that it has new
leadership now and that they are pushing
for GPS tracking of all organs which is
good but these changes have been too
long coming and yunos is not the only
player here remember there are also the
56 organ procurement organizations or
opos each operates exclusively in its
region and is tasked with working with
the families of donors facilitating the
recovery of organs and coordinating
their delivery to the transplant
hospital let me just say the job they do
is very difficult by one estimate less
than 2% of us deaths occur under
circumstances conducive to donation
typically that entails someone being
declared brain dead on a ventilator in a
hospital with oxygen and blood flowing
to their organs and opos have to
approach families for consent at a time
when they're often in shock about what's
just happened that is challenging one
opio even put together a training video
for its workers where they staged
conversations with actors to show what
issues might come up in the heat of that
discussion and it is an absolute roller
coaster ride hi good morning my name is
you know what I already know who you are
and I know what you want and I'm going
to tell you like I told the
doctor you're not touching him we're not
donating if you just give me an
opportunity you know what whoa whoa whoa
stop do you see this here are you
serious right now I've been
sitting here for over a week over a week
I've been sitting here waiting for
someone to come talk to me oh what but
now that they want something now
everybody wants to come talk to me now
right and what they send what this
character in to do what convince
me you're not touching my husband wow
rest in peace both to her fictitious
husband but also to that scenery which
just got chewed up by that acting
Powerhouse we watch a lot of training
videos for this show and believe me that
woman is the meril Streep of the genre
just to catch you up on this the man
declared brain dead is named Jorge and
they've only been married for two months
the guy sitting next to her is Jorge's
brother he doesn't want to makeing
decisions for Jorge and he initially
doesn't want Jorge's organs donated
either but then he remembers that when
they were children their mom who was
working two jobs after their dad left
details that we do not need but that we
get anyway we give them each their own
allowance but jge would give his to his
brother why because he's just that
giving and eventually they both realize
jge would want his organs to be donated
all I'm saying is there is a rich
backstory here now is it the most
gripping medical drama that I've ever
seen no as I've said that would be this
one but it is still unexpectedly good
now a lot of opos try and get ahead of
conversations like that by encouraging
more people in their area to sign up as
organ donors sometimes do advertising
and sometimes even using mascots Gift of
Life Michigan has heartly te heart
Donate Life Wisconsin has Doty the donor
dot donor life Donate Life Arizona has
Reggie the donor Cactus who from that
photo seems to be high on glue and Life
share Oklahoma has Derek the donor who
is an oil Rick because according to the
organization oil is a precious resource
just like organs are a precious resource
except no they are not just like each
other Oklahoma one of those should not
go into your body besides this is just a
bad mascot no one is going to look at
that and think I should sign up to
donate my organs they'll think oh no
that Teletubby is
suffocating and because each opo is
responsible for procuring all the organs
in its area how well it performs has
enormous consequences and yet until
recently that performance has been
determined by the opos themselves since
they've been evaluated on self-reported
data which is a real problem because
opio can fail to Reve organs for many
reasons from exhaustion of over work
staffers to lack of resources and
employees have admitted to gaming the
system to cover up those failures just
listen to this former opo exec I used to
work at an opo and we reported false
numbers to make it appear we were doing
better than we
were imagine there are 10 people who die
and they all have healthy organs that
can save someone's life we might later
falsely report that only four or five of
those people had healthy enough organs
for Don
and make it look like we were more
successful in our recovery effort than
we were in fact we might not even visit
all 10 people that is not good and look
I'm not saying that you can never lie
about death but it's got to be a good
lie like when Robert Patterson went on
the Today Show and said the first time I
went to see the circus somebody died one
of the clowns died his little car
exploded the joke car exploded on him
and then later admitted I actually made
the whole thing up the world is a better
place because of that fake Clown's death
but this is the kind of lie that could
actually kill people the government's
estimated that if opos increase their
performance approximately 5,600 more
organs per year could be transplanted
which is vital because again around
6,000 Americans die each year waiting
for an organ transplant but the problem
is despite the stakes being this High
opos have very little incentive to do
better the government has never
decertified an opo for poor performance
and poor performance can have serious
consequences for people like La poet T
Ingram who desperately needed a kidney
she actually appeared before Congress
two years ago to explain how her
Region's opo one Legacy had failed her
the Oregon procurement organization that
serves Los Angeles where I live is
failing according to the federal
government in fact it's one of the worst
in the country one analysis showed it
only recovered 31% of potential organ
donors some times when you're in this
diagnosis it kind of feels like this is
it and I will just be waiting forever
until I'm no longer here that is awful
and to make it worse the then CEO of one
Legacy Tom moan wrote her an email
defending the job he'd done and
suggesting that the number one thing she
could do to improve your chances and
your community's chances of a
life-saving transplant is to register as
a donor and help people in your ethnic
group in particular to choose to donate
life and if you're ever typing the
phrase your ethnic group into an email
clippy should just appear and say no
stop what you're doing right now and I I
have to say one Legacy says they are
deeply regretful for the email which
they want you to know was a personal
communication from Tom moan very much
throwing him under the bus like a kidney
in a box but at this point it should be
clear our system of managing donated
organs is nowhere near where it should
be but depressingly it's actually a
paragon of care and thoughtful
compared to what happens when someone
donates their body to science which
brings us to whole body donation that is
a choice thousands of Americans make
every year either for themselves or when
a loved one's organs aren't suitable for
donation and it is absolutely essential
to both scientific research and medical
training as this med school video will
attest the beauty and complexity of the
human body can really only be taught
through the process of studying an
anatomical donor donations provide a
tactile sense of learning and really
highlight the variation amongst human
beings in a way that virtual reality
just can't yet I think that this program
allows people to practice and to learn
in a way that will really help their
future patients exactly donations to
science can help doctors better
understand the human body for example if
I donated my body maybe they could
figure out how a man can age 47 years in
a single decade it doesn't seem like it
should be bi logically possible I'm
probably going to be fine I'm going to
live forever and in theory that is great
unfortunately in practice you might not
end up in front of medical students
instead you could end up here on a
bright Sunday morning in Portland
earlier this month this is somebody that
donated their body to science a few
dozen people spent the day inside at
this Downtown hotel they paid up to $500
a seat in the ballroom to sit up close
to the mysterious figure draped in a
white sheet heard about it through a
friend decided to broaden my experiences
the sheet comes off exposing the corpse
of an 86-year-old man this in-person
Pay-Per-View event puts regular people
paying customers within an arms length
of something usually reserved for
doctors and scientists okay clearly a
Marriott Hotel autopsy is stretching the
definition of Science and not to get
sidetracked but did that guy say he
heard about it through a friend because
there's only one way that conversation
should go your friend says hey want to
go to a live autopsy to which you say
I'm sorry what to which he says yeah
they're dissecting a body to which you
say what kind of animal to which he says
no it's a human man to which you respond
why would anyone go all the way to a
medical school to watch to which he
drops with oh no it's not at a medical
school it's in the ballroom of a Marriot
in downtown Portland but we have to be
out by three there's a kinera to which
you reply wait what now to which he says
yeah and it's only $500 again in to
which your only response should be I'll
pay you $500 right now to never speak to
me ever again this friendship is over
and I will say the explanation offered
by the man who hosted that event wasn't
great the body buyer death science.org
is run by Jeremy Certo who has no
professional credentials it was Certo
who brought the Portland Body show to
life and had planned one for Seattle as
well on Halloween day can you guarantee
they had knowledge that he knew that his
body would be used in this way I can
guarantee that he knew his body would be
used for um medical education oh
and I've got to say I'm not
surprised that that long lost member of
My Chemical Romance doesn't have any
medical credentials but that still
doesn't explain why he's somehow
providing medical education and yet that
is totally legal because bodies donated
to science are bought and sold in a
virtually unregulated Market there is no
federal law and no government agency
monitors what happens to kavas pledged
for use in medical research and
education there are also no
government-mandated nonprofits here
instead there are for-profit companies
known as body Brokers or as they prefer
to be called non-transplant tissue Banks
who very literally sell bodies off for
parts one of the few rules that even
applies to them is a statute adopted in
47 States called The Uniform Anatomical
Gift Act that requires donors must
provide informed consent with those
agreements typically stipulating that
the body will be used for research and
education but medical research and
education is not clearly defined and as
you just saw that can technically mean
that your body might be carved up in a
Marriot for the entertainment of a grown
man in a
fedora and even organizations that do
Supply bodies to medical schools like
illino uh Anatomical Gift Association
can conduct themselves poorly it was
accused by one employee of mishandling
mistreating bodies leaving some rotting
or being eaten by rats which is clearly
horrific rats should not be hungrily
devouring human bodies they should be
hungrily devouring each other's bodies I
think we've made our position on that
pretty
clear and while the AG said that it
strongly disagreed with the employees
allegations of mistreatment that
employee also says that he was punished
for speaking out and in the grossest
possible way Mr Wheatley says that when
he approached his super supervisors with
his concerns about procedures three
dismembered heads from donated bodies
were left at his desk my boss walked by
I asked him why the heads were at my
desk and he told me they need to get
back with their bodies so we can send
them to Cremation I said I understand
that why are they at my desk and he told
me well I don't know Dale there's a lot
of strange things happening holy I
don't know Dale there's a lot of of
strange things happening if you are bold
enough to leave severed heads at
someone's desk why be passive aggressive
either you're a direct Communicator or
you are not pick a
lane and body Brokers will sometimes
make attractive pictures to obtain
bodies a struggling families might be
told that they'll receive a crated
portion of their loved one free of
charge other times families might be
told that their loved one's body will be
used to research the exact condition
that they die from which is a lovely
idea but it's just not always the case
take what happened with Cody Sanders who
died at age 24 from a rare disease and
I'll let his mother explain what
happened next we couldn't afford a
barrial for Cody Cody's mom Angie says
someone told her about a company that
could help restore Life USA offered to
handle all of the expenses in exchange
for using some of Cody's body for
medical research all I remember is they
were supposed to take skin
cells so they could figure out maybe
they could figure out that what caused
this disease you can see why that would
be so appealing for her and it's what
makes it so upsetting that a month after
Cody died a reporter from Reuters bought
her son's cervical spine for $300 plus
shipping from that company and if you're
thinking how the was that allowed
to happen well in almost every state it
is legal to sell the human remains of
adults there are multiple weap websites
where you can buy human bones Skulls
Unlimited which is actually the company
that owned that bone museum you saw
earlier sell skeletons that it
guarantees our antiques decades old
human bones once used in places like
medical schools but under most States
laws they don't have to be and it is a
good business by the way they will sell
you a human skull for $2,200 or a rib
for $40 you can even buy human teeth for
$35 a pop which is a pretty great deal
in the reason I know that is we bought
two dozen of them except of course we
didn't relax we're not
monsters but we could have done it if we
wanted to and I am very disappointed by
how many people in this room seem
genuinely worried that we might have
done that
unbelievable and you might be thinking
well this whole story has horrified me
so much I'm keeping everything inside me
and I'm taking it to my grave but it's
really important to reiterate just how
meaningful organ donation in particular
can be take what happened to Alyssa
sandine who would have died without a
heart transplant and 10 years ago one
became available after this 20-year-old
Kate leaky was tragically killed by a
drunk driver that transplant saved
Alyssa's life and a few years later
Alyssa met Kate's family and the result
was incredibly moving Alyssa decided to
meet Kate's family over the weekend they
made the drive to Illinois when they got
there Kate's parents and sister were
waiting finally two families bonded by a
special gift met face to
face it's so nice to meet you Alyssa
came with her own gift a stuffed teddy
bear for the mother to keep with a
sound we made a recording of my
heartbeat with a
stethoscope and we decided to give that
to her so she can keep her daughter's
heart with
her that's your daughter's
heartbeat like just to hear her
heartbeat I can't explain it that is
amazing and let us all agree that Alyssa
absolutely nailed that gift that is
about as thoughtful as gift giving gets
it is certainly better than what I would
have done desperately look at Hallmark
cards and then accidentally buy one that
says happy
graduation the point is we all know Don
eating organs saves lives and giving
your body to science can save and
enhance them too but what we currently
do with those gifts is broken far too
many people are dying waiting for organs
that could be coming but aren't and one
of them sadly is Tanya Ingram who died
last year never having gotten the
transplant that she was waiting for so
what can we do well for organs we need
to raise the standards of how the system
operates and there's actually some good
news on that front from and I cannot
believe I'm about to say this the Trump
Administration it actually put a rule in
place that provides an objective rather
than self-reported metric for measuring
the performance of opos and starting in
2026 opos who fall below a certain
standard will lose their contract it is
one of exactly two good things that we
got from the Trump Administration
alongside this spectacular gay rabbit
now that new rule is not perfect some
experts worry that uh the standards
might punish good opos by not properly
adjusting for things that aren't in
their control while also allowing
struggling opos an opportunity to gain
the system one particular worry is the
so-called pancreas exception which lets
opos claim credit for pancreases that
aren't transplanted but are recovered
for research and it's not a great sign
that one underperforming opo in Ohio
life bank went from recovering one
pancreas for research the year before
the new standards were released
to1 so far this year also for what it's
worth the pancreas exception sounds like
a Director D DVD Thriller from 2003
starring Nicholas Cage as for Unos this
past September President Biden signed a
bill that could split up its contract
and allow others including for-profit
companies to compete for parts of the
services that it now provides will that
improve the efficiency of our national
system let's hope so but the jurry is
currently out as for whole bodies
donated for research there is a law
awaiting a VOE in Congress right now
that would ensure donated bodies are not
unknowingly contributed to a for
industry which seems like a pretty good
idea but even as we are waiting for
these long overdue improvements let me
be very clear about something here I am
an organ donor when I die and someone is
in need of these subpar organs they can
have atom and nothing that we've
researched or covered tonight however
unpleasant it's been has changed my mind
about that decision and while personally
I wouldn't mind being a skeleton doing a
back flip in a museum I know that my
family might have some objections to
that so if you want to and you haven't
already you should sign up to donate
your organs you can do that at register
me.org if you want to look into being a
living Kidney donor you can learn more
at organdonor.gov
and whether you want to denote your
organs or your whole body you should
probably have a conversation with your
family now about it and I know it's not
easy to talk to them about this or
indeed anything but it is it is really
important cuz remember lives are hanging
in the balance here these donations are
immensely generous gifts and we all
deserve a system that is worthy of that
generosity one that operates with
efficiency saves as many lives as
possible and that at the very least
ensures every heart makes its Airline
connection and nobody's body
unexpectedly winds up sliced and diced
in a two star business Hotel it's just
not too much to ask that is our show
thank you so much for watching we will
see you next week and now I will leave
you with a few more glorious seconds of
the most intense training video ever
produced I know that what he was found
down 911 was called who was the person
that's the first person that was
notified yeah she was contacted first
yeah you think she had any nerve to call
me about anything you know how many
times it's getting a little heavy in
here you doing
[Music]
okay